hello folks
welcome to rational science the only
site on youtube that does physics
right we uh
we do something different everybody else
yes we do
everybody else does
math
technology
and irrational explanations
what we do here is rational explanations
and we divide our uh lecture in three
parts the first part we do extinction
specifically we want to get to the
notion of the extinction of man but in
order to get there we need to know what
a mass extinction is
and that's what this channel does as far
as extinction is concerned we do a
little bit of physics today we have
refraction what is refraction
and then at the end we're gonna answer
questions
that people made since last time
okay uh so let's get on with extinction
and i'm gonna start with a comment that
someone made
it was regarding an interview i had a
week ago now um
with ed dutton okay interview slash
debate okay and this is what this file
says says
uh bill mean right saying humans will go
extinct ed asks why and bill answers
because we have no genetic diversity
no absolutely not i never said that and
so the question is whether this
individual even watched
the show i mean i don't know where he
got that where he thinks that
i'm proposing that humans will disappear
because of genetic diversity of some
issue with genetic diversity supposedly
that we lost genetic diversity
and here's another fellow along the same
lines and he says um
yes how much amazing
gossipy is required for mass extinction
and the answer is none
mass extinctions have nothing to do
with
genetics
okay
at least the animals right so so let's
get the
the idea at least the the basics here
okay mass extinction has nothing to do
really with genetic diversity that's got
to do with genetic diversity has to do
with a background extinction the
extinction of one
species a single species okay
mass extinction it's an economic
collapse
that's what a mass extinction is okay
it's the elimination of an entire food
chain
okay
animals which are dependent on each
other
and um
it's a ecological pyramid overturn
that's the short version the synthesis
of that and there you have it the first
one is that the plants overturn their uh
pyramid okay their uh ecological pyramid
their population pyramid or sorry and
why because they lose genetic diversity
and they are an old species that's why
so orders of plants entire orders of
plants disappear
and the animals that forge relationships
with them for a long time disappear with
them they can't change their eating
habits at the last moment
and that's when the ecological pyramid
overturns okay
and here you have
another vision of that okay again it's
an economic collapse and one file says
economic collapse has never been a
factor before in any other species
extinction
and the answer is uh well this is what
this site proposes this site says that
it has
happened it's always happened that way
it's the only mechanism mother nature
uses
uh economic collapse so you have to
understand what an economic collapse
means what what that term means and it's
not that there the stock market just
fell that's not what we're talking about
what we're talking about is the elim
elimination
of
uh primary production production and it
disappears all by itself uh we don't
need any asteroids no volcanoes none of
that stuff no catastrophic accidents
what what happens is the plants are old
they've been around for too long
and so their population pyramid
overturns their genetic diversity
disappears and they whittle out and as
they're whittling out all the um
herbivores that relied on that
source of food
suddenly have trouble finding food and
when they start dying so do the
predators that prey on them
and there you have an example the
cretaceous terrestrial revolution what
you see there is that the angiosperms
displaced but specifically the conifers
and within that specifically the cycads
okay so it displaced them uh from the
middle of the cretaceous all the way to
the end
and by doing that by muscling all these
uh plants aside plants on which the
dinosaurs
depended um
that's that's how the dinosaurs
disappeared because they could not
uh find enough food for themselves the
forest the jungles of cycads were
disappearing and probably other conifers
that they ate and they were not eaters
of angiosperms those are flowering
plants okay so there you have an example
of an economic collapse that's what
economic collapse means means the uh
plants disappear
because uh all animals essentially
what they do is
um
they manage
resources what is the resource that all
animals manage food
okay we manage food too we do it a
little different than other animals but
we manage food too in fact we produce
our own food
and we do it what we do it only for
uh monetary gain that's our world that's
the human world it's not the lion world
it's not the alligator world it's our
world but it's the same notion mother
nature works through economic collapses
and humans
according to this site at least will
disappear because of a
grand economic collapse okay once uh the
global economy collapses man's econom
global economy collapses
it can't go any further at some point
it's got to stop and reaches a dead end
starts falling and what do we mean by
that mean that money will be no more you
can't use money for anything any kind of
money no bitcoin no gold no fiat money
nothing
and the only thing of value will be food
you don't trade food in the especially
in the asphalt jungle
where we live cities
okay uh so um
so in yeah
mass extinction has
nothing to do specifically directly
with
genetic diversity but i do address and i
did address in ed dutton's program i did
address as much as i could because you
know he kind of surprised me going in
that direction but that's the direction
the
debate went we went in the direction of
genetic diversity and that's uh what
people want to
hear today because that's very popular
on everybody's mind it's out there the
geneticists had have become
kings out there kings of science they
they call the shots today and everybody
believes them they say well they can't
be wrong you know i mean they count all
these atoms they've got to have it right
and no i'm saying they've got it wrong
and what they've got wrong is
according to me right is uh what
everybody out there takes for granted
and that's that species only gain
genetic diversity through mutations so
everybody is convinced that
any species only gains genetic diversity
and so the question is if every species
gains genetic diversity after thousands
of years
why does the human race all 8 billion of
us have no genetic diversity we have
very very little genetic diversity
together with all the other mammals they
also have very little genetic diversity
but some have more than others and we
don't have too much compared to other
animals yeah specifically we compared
ourselves against the chimps there are
other comparisons out there
we have very little genetic diversity
and you say how can that be true if we
have eight billion people on the planet
and we're producing new people every day
and we have all these minor these uh
small um
uh
mutations
don't they add up
and so yeah so this is my take there
mutation rate increases but what happens
you have all these population
bottlenecks and founder effects which
chop off completely whatever genetic
diversity you collected you accumulated
so so in the end you know this is
supposed to be a sawtooth wave
but the point is that uh we can only
lose any species can only lose genetic
diversity over time and people have a
lot of trouble with that because they
say no no i thought we we increased
genetic diversity well here we are you
the opposite we don't take that
statement for granted which is what all
these geneticists out there believe in
and pass around
okay um
follow says that inbreeding is good uh
referring again to genetic diversity
says inbreeding can be neutral or even
good if done correctly
okay you marry your sister that's good
okay okay
uh selecting the good purging the bad
through a higher mortality rate that's
what he proposes okay
and uh he proposes instead
of inbreeding why don't we try out
breeding okay the one reason
so many issues are happening today might
be exactly for the opposite reasons we
are out breeding so much that we hide
all the mutations of every generation
into each other and then they pop out of
existence and they don't die as we now
often can save them okay so this is his
take on it believes that um
out breeding is is better than
inbreeding
i'm sorry yeah they're reversed that
embry is better than out breeding okay
so we should not
um marry someone
uh who is very distinct from us or very
far away uh genetically farming us we
should marry someone who is much closer
to us and well i don't know i think he's
got it wrong he's got it completely in
reverse i covered that the other day
okay
another fellow says the following along
the same lines he says
the term clone again referring to
inbreeding right
is the answer to genetic diversity in
relation to survival again we're not
talking about
uh the extinction of man it's not going
to happen because of genetic diversity i
want to again clarify that because
people get it wrong okay now it's got to
do with the global economic collapse
nothing to do with genetic diversity or
diversity or the overturning of the uh
population pyramid okay so in relation
to survival if some harrowing by nature
occurs okay mankind continues to clone
itself exactly that's true and like
apples
show the changes with variety of the
same fruit of the tree of life just
different appearances but the same basic
design of survival
okay okay so we're all clones okay he
doesn't see a problem with that he says
chimps are endangered
okay
and need the variety to maintain their
environmental existence along with other
designs that haven't reached human
vegetable or other life with lack of
genetic diversity in other words clones
so he's saying it's good for
chimps or that they need to have this
diversity for otherwise they wouldn't
survive
but it turns out that um
uh you have other animals that he
apparently hasn't touched upon
and the
famous one i guess you could say is the
cheetah okay the cheetah
cheetahs
and what these animals do is uh marry
amongst themselves i guess they've had
some problems in the past apparently and
today they have very very little genetic
diversity i think it's the animal
at least a four-legged animal with least
amount of genetic diversity on the
planet or at least one of them and here
you see from the folks at berkeley and
they say the following and this uh this
puts genetic diversity in its proper
context says loosely genetic variation
is a measure of the genetic differences
within a population a population in
which every individual has the same gene
version allele at a particular location
in the genome has less genetic variation
for that gene than a population in which
many individuals carry different gene
versions of at that location
and a population with no genetic
variation in which every individual is
genetically identical essentially right
cannot evolve in response to
environmental or situational changes
okay so these folks have in mind what
everybody every geneticist spits out
there and they say well if you don't
have genetic diversity uh you're not fit
or not as fit
to survive if there are environmental
or for example
diseases you know changes out there okay
that's that's their argument
and uh well i have a lot to say about
that i think it's it's nonsense okay
what they say what all these geneticists
say and i'll tell you about that in a
minute if for example a genetically
uniform population were exposed to a new
pathogen there you have it and did not
carry the new gene version the gene
versions necessary to fend off disease
the population would face complete
extinction
okay
i have no problem with that part i have
problem with with the other part and
that's putting it in the historical
context that's what no geneticist on
planet earth has ever done
okay they don't put in in the proper
context
okay let's find out
here we have uh
same from berkeley they talk about the
cheetah okay so as a species cheetahs
have famously low levels of genetic
variation yeah it's it's pretty famous
those who
have done a little bit of research will
find a cheetah immediately in there this
can probably be attributed to it do
these people know anything about history
to a population bottleneck they
experienced around 10 000 years ago
barely avoiding extinction at the end of
the last ice age okay however the
situation has worsened in
modern times
it's worsened because
um we have crowded out a lot of these
animals
uh in africa in africa where they are
today you know so we've crowded them out
in other words
we took away their uh land
and they're they're they have to live in
ever smaller spaces that's essentially
the problem today that's why they they
say situation has worsened
the question is um
the bottleneck
the bottleneck and the founders effect
that's what created that situation
that's why the cheetahs have very little
genetic diversity today despite the fact
that whether they say in 10 000 years
they've been creating
mutations i guess all along
how come all these cheetahs don't have
lots of diversity after 10 000 years
that's what you got to ask yourself i
mean
okay so they had a big
crash
great and
we had 10 000 years for these cheetahs
to recover
and today they have hardly any genetic
diversity left
think about that okay unlike the champs
okay
the fact that female cheetah very young
with many different fathers you know
they have one here and one there with
the other one okay helps preserve what
little genetic variation the species has
left and could even buy us some time in
our efforts uh conserve these endangered
animals
uh
i always say my
point on that one people don't
don't appreciate it but maybe 99 of the
people out there will say i'm wrong and
won't like what i have to say but i say
we should kill
kill murder assassinate exterminate
all dangerous animals
we don't need them we don't need lions
we don't need tigers we don't need
elephants we don't need any alligators
sharks we don't need any of those
animals bears wolves get rid of them we
have the power let's do it
and
i'm saying we don't need those animals
and people say oh but then you upset the
balance of nature that's like saying
that because the woolly willie mammoth
went away and upset the balance of
nature
no nothing happened he just went away
and we all continued living in fact if
we upset the balance of nature like you
know we removed the lions and now the
buffalo and the zebras start multiplying
let's kill them too
we have no use for zebras or buffaloes
or uh dogs out there the
wild dogs
or hyenas none of those and we have no
use for them whatsoever now you say well
it's nice to have variety you mean for
our pleasure is that why we have them
out there
is that why we
keep these animals alive this is is that
why we conserve them and try to look for
species that are on the verge of
extinction and try to save them some way
i'm saying we should do the opposite
i mean if i'm correct
and humans are about to become extinct
it is a mood issue whether we kill all
animals on earth that we do not use
you know we use cows because we eat them
we
eat pigs we eat the chickens no problem
there
if uh if you want to make uh bags out of
alligator skins fine then you know get
them into your yard put a industry and
start breeding alligators or crocodiles
or whatever but if we are not going to
do something like that kill them all we
don't need these animals we don't need
sharks we don't need
crocodiles we don't need lions or tigers
you want to see one go to youtube you'll
find all kinds here
okay
you don't need them in circuses we don't
need them in
zoos
we don't need animals that are dangerous
especially the dangerous ones but we
don't need some of the others either i
mean we can get rid of all wildlife on
earth
like it good idea
don't hit me
i know a lot of people will kill me for
the sake and all that okay um
so they continue they say look this is
what the cheetah does she goes out and
she has uh different mates and that
expands her diversity because if she
sleeps with this one and that one that
one has kids with each one
uh well all these kids are gonna be a
little different but if they come out of
a single parent a single father well
then you don't have much diversity in
there that's that's their argument and
so they're trying to save the cheetah
okay
i'm not sure it's uh oh by the way i say
that we're doing them a favor if we
exterminate them by the way
and you say well how's that doing done
my favorite
them is doing them a favor yeah because
see then they don't suffer that slow
death that mother nature has planned for
them where they're disappearing little
by little and here is here are the
humans uh trying to save each one
uh on life they're putting all these
animals on life support you know with
little uh tubes down their mouth to see
if they live and the guys on the
operating table they're dying and say no
let them live let them live it's the
last species on earth you know
no you don't want them to die a slow
death it's uh i think that's more
painful than just liquidating all of
them and then if you want to watch a
lion you got to do it like you watch the
mammoth you go to youtube or whatever in
maybe a movie or an uh i don't know a
documentary
and you watch the animal how it used to
be how's that are we gonna preserve the
lines for the next million years is that
what these people think
okay let's see if we can preserve
ourselves for a million years first okay
which is another
issue which is a really a more uh
pressing issue okay
okay another fellow says humans started
when the bible said right
okay god made two people in there
they're the end okay every species
starts out like this how could we have
less genetic diversity than the original
two
okay
when you have sex the notion is you will
get more genetic diversity when a
species started in breeding is when
there were less of a species made when
when did the species in any case
in any sense of species ever get less
made
okay so again
it's got to do with this notion
he probably missed the
talk the other day
i said that yeah mutations accumulate
but they
accumulate incrementally very little
it takes centuries like i said the other
day takes centuries to create quite a
bit of genetic diversity through
mutations
and then here comes a disease it just
wipes out half of humanity
a big bottleneck
well all that genetic diversity is lost
the other issue is that you don't even
have to wait for a catastrophe of that
nature
gargantuan
catastrophe all you got to look at is
that until the beginning of the 19th
century half of the children below the
age of five died
uh our forefathers saw death
much more often than we do today today
we lived to the age of a hundred the old
days very few people lived to the age of
the hundred except the ones in the bible
you know metro salon so uh they lived a
long time but uh people lived only to
the the average
at the turn of the 20th century was uh
40 years old
because so many kids
died young
and they died of what of childhood
diseases in other words we had not
reached an agreement with uh endemic
diseases um
that you know that were around in those
days today we nobody dies of endemic
diseases we've conquered them all
essentially you know either through
vaccines if that's what you believe in
or through
um our natural selection the fact that
those forefathers who could not
withstand the diseases died and those
who could
gave birth to us
that's the way it works
okay so um
yeah so let's look at what a bottleneck
is here we have a population bottle and
let's find out what this means for those
of you who are not familiar an event
that drastically reduces the size of a
population
chops off half the population like you
know the 14th century bubonic plague
wiped out between the third and
half of europe
and so all that genetic diversity that
we accumulated through mutations was
chopped off in one shot well what was it
uh
1348 i think it lasted like three or
four years
and uh wiped out anywhere from a third
to a
half of the population of europe those
are the numbers that we get from the
little villages where they do the
census you know who died who didn't
that's more or less the numbers they
came up with
okay the typical causes are
environmental disaster that could happen
in a sudden
sudden something that happens suddenly
okay
over predation you know uh
you could be over hunting
uh i think that's less likely maybe
that's only applicable to man
um habitat destruction we do a lot of
that we crowd out all the other
especially the wild species
and disease disease is the number one
and that's the one that always kept us
in check humans okay it was disease okay
okay and uh the other issue is founder
effect okay so we have
population bottleneck and founder effect
and that's a reduction in genetic
variation that results when a small
subset of a large population is used to
establish a new colony in other words
you have a branching out
of
a group from the main trunk
okay and i'm saying that's what happened
that's how neanderthal came to be you
had um
homo erectus he walked all the way to
rape britain or thereabouts maybe france
maybe
spain
from there came uh another level of
human
like or
uh
hominid
which was antecessor
possibly together with heidelberg man of
heidelberg
homo heidelbergensis
and from that
we have neanderthal
and what we're saying here is that
these were branches that came out
heidelberg came out of a branch from the
main trunk which was
um
homo erectus and then neanderthal came
out of a branch
of
heidelberg
that's that's the assumption i make
that's the theory and the assumption
that i work with okay sonya anderthal
was born
in europe but his uh great grandfather
was
homo erectus which was our great
grandfather that's more or less a story
ours was a great grandfather in spain in
africa and uh
neanderthal was had this great
grandfather homo erectus in europe in
arctic europe and so i think that's how
these two species came to be we were two
different species and that's what the
founder effect is a group branches out
from the main trunk
encounters a new environment okay and
new lands etc new diseases
okay new predators new
uh possible plants if that's
or even animals that they hunted
and then you see the the little picture
shows you you know how that's done how
um
that that's how mother nature selects
species or or
uh
makes species okay
and i think that's how we came to be
okay
let's continue here um
uh i'm saying that humans now because of
this
lengthy process
have lost genetic diversity they lost
genetic diversity why because
we had lots of
population bottlenecks followed by
founders effects and that streams line
that streamlines our genetic code
and i'm saying that because of that we
have very rare diseases today mental
problems today that you see
out there okay
and here's a specific one specific
example
and it's um
siamese twins okay
now one file says well you know sammy's
twins in the old days uh perhaps women
didn't want to show that to the doctor
or to their husband or whatever and just
drown the thing in the
in the river
okay it could have happened that's true
but i doubt that i i'm saying i think
that what happened here was that
it wasn't documented because i think
it's a modern problem two-headed
children or
or
you know conjoined twins in some some
way through their shoulders or their
pelvis or whatever
i think these are genetic problems and
they are genetic problems that come
when a species loses
its genetic diversity
and uh you know i i was saying sometime
back that you know i had peach trees i
have a peach tree and
i found that five of the peaches
uh came out uh as siamese
and i gather from this that the peach
is a very old plant
and that more or less uh was confirmed
to me when i found out that the original
peaches were the size of a grape
and it's through a mixture of natural
selection and
artificial selection that we made the
peaches to what they are today you know
more or less a
tennis ball size
and that's how they used to be and today
now they're big their old plants are big
plants for what they used to be
and now we're having two headed
peaches and not only peaches we have a
lot of siamese fruits and veggies out
there you can look them up just google
siamese veggies and
fruits and you'll find there's quite a
bit today why because all these plants
have lost their genetic diversity for
the most part okay says this is the
first case that i can find that you can
more or less put your hand in the fire
floor it's not a direct
um
proof
because it's a theophanies and he
talked about what
george george cinquelos or since ellis
um
wrote friend of his
and they got it they didn't get it
firsthand they got it from probably one
of these two guys from the fourth
century because they're talking about
something that happened in the fourth
century
so they weren't the first ones to see it
but if you look at if you read that
it'll say you know that
they found uh two i guess a boy and a
girl that were united in some
way
and uh one died and the other one died
four days later which is pretty much
what happens to a lot of siamese twins
and
this case assuming this is the first
case or one of the first cases document
undocumented you're talking about the
fourth century if this happened then
nobody else talked too much about these
things it's because we had not
we didn't have that many cases at all or
maybe
maybe a couple on earth
and today we're having a whole bunch of
these we have if you look up siamese
twins we're getting a lot of them
why because we lost our genetic
diversity that's my argument okay
and uh this is the more
i guess the one one that you can put
your hand in the fire for this one was
testified by a lot of people witnessed
by a lot of people and it's two gals in
hungary who were
conjoined at the hip
or the pelvis
so uh
these these are modern problems and
remember again very few cases in the
19th century if you look it up you'll
find that
uh there are a lot more cases today look
at coin joint twins look them up you'll
find that it's a it's a problem that's
increasing you're you're seeing more and
more now you might say well the
population has increased which is also
true
the question is uh um we're having more
cases and the question this is just an
issue of the fact that we
write about it today and take pictures
because it's an unusual event or is it
that we are actually having more and
more cases because we have genetic
problems and i keep mentioning the amish
we've been married
in breeding for
300 years and they're having all kinds
of genetic problems so inbreeding is not
a good idea as these other fellows
suggest they think it's better to do
inbreeding and outbreathing uh i would
say
that i discourage it completely
don't sleep with your sister
okay let's move on to
refraction
and
what is refraction well refraction is
that light comes into through a film and
instead of bouncing back
ricochet shading or you know uh bouncing
backwards it uh goes through but it
doesn't go in a straight line like
transparency would it goes off in some
direction some angle
that's essentially it that's refraction
description in a nutshell okay but one
person accuses me says bill but you
haven't explained transparency very well
i thought i did he says the following he
says um
uh
you vaguely
uh depicted it you didn't actually
explain refraction transparency opacity
in the least
i thought i did but
not that refraction because
today's refraction
you got to give me time to talk about
them you know opacity i haven't talked
about that either so i i thought i'd
talk about transparency and i thought i
gave you the
mechanism so let's find out if i did or
not because this fellow accuses me says
you didn't talk about transparency or
you didn't explain it i thought i did
let's find out uh he says what
physically what's physically different
about transparent versus opaque media
well that's a separate issue that's a
separate question
one thing is to give you a mechanism for
transparency another one is the question
you're asking is what is the difference
between this and then how is this
different than what's happening in each
case
that's a separate issue but to say that
i haven't explained transparency
why uh film is transparent
i thought i did well we'll cover it
today anyway so that you'll learn it
well okay
what physically happens at the rope atom
boundary to cause torsion to be
redirected
again he's talking about refraction
that's today okay the phenomena uh don't
really follow from rh assumptions you
have to explain them yeah you have to
explain them but uh if you explain any
other person's not listening uh well
i can't do much about that you know
so uh try to listen okay maybe maybe you
missed something okay
okay uh give me a second here
okay here we move on
and i fell along the same lines but this
is one of the reasons uh i i like to
cover the subject again i thought it
covered transparency but he this guy
also
apparently got the wrong message he says
as object looks transparent an object
looks transparent because light waves
pass through
unchanged
he says the the waves are not touching
anything they're just going through the
material
that's what he's saying there okay the
light wave effectively passes through
unchanged as a result we can see
straight through
almost as though the object isn't even
there
okay
and the first problem we have is
he uses the word wave
well there you have a wave and what is a
wave well wave is a bunch of vectors
there's no physical object called a wave
the flag you can say waves what is
waving the flag
wave is what it does
ocean wave well it's the water
so it's the water that's waving
okay waving is what it's what water does
okay it's a wave is a verb so the
question is if light
is waving or something is waving and
that's what we call light what is it
that is waving
you have to identify that what
that thing
and you can't say a wave does this
because wave is just a bunch of vectors
according to the mathematical
establishment unless you've got
something else i don't know but that's
what we have vectors and vectors is a
mathematical concept it's just uh
magnitude and direction and what the
mathematicians have done is they put
them in motion
all these numbers with direction
very scary stuff
so no there is no such thing as a wave
but even assuming we concede it
look at what this fellow is saying he's
saying that light passes through
just goes through
the film
and doesn't touch anything
okay that's what he's saying so
you know imagine uh you're looking at a
pool water
and you can see your reflection at the
bottom
and someone might say well now you're
really seeing your reflection at the top
at the surface
uh
lesson
slap slap
throw a nickel down 10 feet of water in
a pool swimming pool which is crystal
clear you'll see the coin at the bottom
of the pool
so don't tell me it's the reflection at
the top of the pool you can see through
water all the way your coin at the
bottom 10 feet of water okay or whatever
okay yeah so you can't use the wave but
even if you use a wave let's see
assuming you concede it
you grant it you say okay let's concede
the wave then what even so this spell is
saying that the wave goes through all
these atoms
that feet of water gazillions of
atoms
all the way to the bottom and all the
way to the top i would think right
because if you can see your reflection
all the way down at the bottom
you can see your your shadow at the
bottom
for sure you can see the coin
that means at least one way you're gonna
get uh the image of the coin through
gazillions of atoms or molecules of
water
and the wave didn't touch anything just
went through all of it
my god
and this is the the problem that people
have these
uh notions that
they get them from um
experiment and from observing
and that's why observation and
uh experimentation are not part of the
scientific method
not according to
what this site does okay what the
mathematicians do we don't care we're
saying science okay in science we don't
use observation or experiments because
you reach these
uh irrational conclusions which are
easily debunked
and in fact the establishment uh
a lot of people hold it in fact uh
this notion and here you have a an
example here's how stuff works i showed
it the other day okay and these people
say because air contains so few atoms
light waves run into very few of them
when they shine through air that's their
explanation so the air looks transparent
if you put enough dust in the air the
particles of dust absorb the light and
the air stops being transparent
so these people think just like this
follow here that it's a hit and miss
type of the issue you know that
uh perhaps
when you throw your coin
down 10 feet of water crystal clear
water in the pool right you can see it
there you can throw your shoe if the
coin is too little throw your shoe down
there and you'll see it down there and
you can see it right through the water
and so here's the shoe sending you
photons
through gazillions of atoms vertically
right lined up vertically through all
these atoms of water
i guess
it you know zigzags through all of them
is that how it makes it all the way to
the top
is this what these people really think
i mean they haven't figured this out
they think it's a question of oh if it
doesn't hit then it goes through
and i mean is there any chance that any
photon can make it through 10 feet of
gazillions
of
molecules of water
and not hit a single one
my god
so we have a problem we have a problem
because people don't understand the
basics and that's why we've got to go
back to transparency before we can
understand you know we can move on these
people this fella is asking a question
of college college question he says well
you haven't explained transparency you
moved on you want to do refraction yeah
but see
if you don't understand the kindergarten
stuff
i'm not going to move on to
the college stuff
so let's make sure you understand the
kindergarten stuff first and right now
people have a
big problem understanding the
kindergarten stuff okay you can see
these folks think that
light is goes through air
and what i'm going to argue today is
light doesn't go through walls of any
kind let's get it straight light does
not go through any kind of wall i don't
care if the wall is made out of steel
cement
air
water
or glass or whatever
light does not go through any kind of
wall light does not go through atoms
light does not go through molecules
we got that straight
that's kindergarten stuff okay light
does not go through atoms through
molecules to walls of any kind
okay so we're gonna show this and until
you understand transparency i don't know
if we can talk about anything else i
mean here
and so one side says
uh quantity of atoms have no bearing on
transparency absolutely okay so
if a film is transparent it's uh well
it's got to some degree to do with
thickness with how wide it is but
primarily that's not the mechanism it's
not that if you have lots of atoms it
blocks light
okay and if you have few atoms light
goes through no such monster
light does not go through walls light
does not go through atoms light does not
go through molecules okay if the
chemical bonds in a
substance have the right energy to
absorb in the visible spectrum you can
see through it
okay so we have energy whatever that is
it's going to be absorbed
so it absorbs the energy so if it
observed the atom absorbs it doesn't let
it go through
but if for some reason it doesn't absorb
it or
i don't know it stimulates the electron
the electron re-emits
okay
transmits again re-transmits
okay so that's maybe how light gets
behind the atom goes through it okay
that's what these people are saying
so he says uh if they absorb in the
infrared and ultraviolet instead such as
glass light travels through
this is what these people think that if
it's not absorbed light travels through
the film
through the wall
does your cat go through the wall
well what's different from light
from from your cat
i mean try it i mean just throw your cat
against the wall until you go through
that's what these people are saying that
uh you can throw the photon against the
wall and some some of them will go
through
okay
so so keep this in mind this is what
these people are saying that light goes
through walls that's what these people
are saying
i'm going to argue here that light does
not go through walls i don't care what
the whole wall is made of
okay i don't care if it's a crystal i
don't care if it's uh silicon dioxide
water air it doesn't matter light does
not go through atoms light does not go
through walls
hey let's find out here
because this is the notion people have
they got it from intuition from
observing and doing experiments that's
why those are not important what's
important in science is that you think
that you use your brain not that you use
your eyes or hands
okay and this is another version of that
says materials are transparent why
because to these wavelengths of light
for which there is no mechanism within
the material to absorb those wavelengths
again all these people say more or less
the same thing
and glass electrons require much more
energy before they can skip from one
energy band to another back again in
other words you have this quantum jump
and if the photon comes in and
uh
knocks that electron that's in the lower
orbital and it gives it energy and so
now the
electron jumps to a higher orbital and
re-emits you know the uh
the um
sometimes some people say it just
absorbs the other one says it re-emits
the uh
the signal the energy or whatever
consequently photons of visible light
what travel through glass these people
think that light travels through walls
okay let's get that's right this is what
all these people say that light travels
through walls that's what they believe
okay instead of being absorbed or
reflected okay let's find out if all
this is true does light travel through
walls does your cat travel through walls
that's fine now maybe the ghost does i
don't know
but cats
i don't think so
okay and so here's a foul who tries to
explain transparency he says reflection
of light occurs when the waves
waves what is a wave i guess it's that
moving vectors again
encounter a surface that does not absorb
the energy
energy i guess one of these
uh souls these spirits called energy
of the radiation and bounces here you
have the energy bouncing jesus
bounces the waves away from the surface
okay for instance a blue hat is blue
because it is absorbing light okay so it
absorbs light whatever that is whatever
he meant by that what do you mean
absorbs light what did it absorb i mean
was it a liquid a
bunch of particles what did it absorb
but bouncing the blue spectrum back he
bounces the spectrum
okay everything we see is reflecting
well how about refracting i mean
if everything is reflecting i mean i
stand behind a glass
and reflection would be
the guy on the other side right so he's
he's being reflected in the mirror in
the glass but i see him through the
glass so i think that's refracting
so everything is not reflecting there we
have reflecting and we have refracting
and those are not the same thing okay we
call them something different
when reflecting is like when you're in
the mirror when you see yourself in a
pool like uh narcissus the other day
right
but if the
thing goes through and the fish sees you
from underneath the water well he's he's
your light is being refracted through
that water okay not reflecting okay we
measure these waves with instruments
such as photo photometers and
spectrometers okay i don't know how you
can measure a wave whatever a wave is
these waves are not conceptual
okay so they're physical objects let's
find out we can see them whoa
you can see the wave
okay you can see with tools i don't care
with what just draw it for me we can
touch them well if you touch them you
should be able to draw it
give me a drawing of a wave when we find
out what it is okay what does it look
like does it look like those vectors
there and mathematical vectors is that
what it is
uh ever get had a sunburn yeah but uh so
what causes the sunburn is it uh ghosts
i mean i i could say it's the spirits
that do that as well right what's the
difference between the wave your wave
and the spirit
looks like you're talking about spirits
we
says um
we can measure them as three dimensions
in
our three-dimensional environment waves
have shape
oh yeah what do they look like
and what are we talking about what is
this shape
i mean again are we talking about these
uh
these um vectors is that what a wave is
to you i mean if not uh it'd be nice if
you can
point to a site that shows what your
waves are okay
to call these waves a concept is
ignorant
it's that simple what the hell do we
measure with oscilloscope a concept
well you got to tell us what it is see
you're talking about a what
and if you're going to talk about a what
you got to
define what a what is and what is a what
and we're talking about an object
and this is what an object is
an object is that which has shape okay
and here you see there's no object in
science called or physics called a wave
and a wave is equal to a verb that's
what a wave is transverse wave is moving
vectors so you can't use the word wave
you got to know what an object is and
here's the object okay
objects what
an object is not what that which you can
see or touch an object is that which has
shape and you're saying that that thing
has shape there well no because that's
that's a concept we're talking about
concepts we're talking about vectors
uh
magnitude and direction and that are
moving and so they fooled you
they they sold you a whopper they sold
you a whopper that saying that what
you're staring at is a physical object
when it's just uh
what they did to the mathematicians but
a number there which uh is that the
arrows going up and sideways and then he
started moving these arrows so no there
is no such thing as a wave you got to
figure out what if what uh
physical object mediates light
and shape is the only universal property
of objects there is no object you can
imagine that doesn't have shape
concepts don't have shape and so if you
think that's a physical object well
think again
that's not a physical object what you're
staring at is a bunch of vectors
mathematical vectors and those do not
qualify as physical objects
okay
give me a second here get rid of these
okay
so uh
when you look at these people they say
okay so we have these waves
and
if they travel through a medium
and a medium for some reason doesn't
absorb them doesn't stop them
the light goes right through the medium
and reaches your eye
and so here we have an example we have
these waves of light coming from who
maybe a star or a galaxy
and what these people are saying is that
when these waves approach the earth the
air in our
that covers our earth
uh the particles that don't block the
waves
uh you know those waves will go through
and reach your eye that's what these
people are saying
okay and that's strange because you know
the official version is that the reason
you see the sky blue or light blue is
that uh there's refraction going on not
that you're receiving the wave directly
from
from the star from from wherever out
there in space
okay so uh there's something wrong here
so there's a contradiction in what these
people are saying they're saying uh
light that doesn't get caught comes to
your eye
and turns out the light always a is blue
and it's blue
why because they say
the uh air scatters
the light
and only allows
that frequency that is bluish to reach
your eye that's a different story than
saying that light goes through air and
doesn't get caught by any molecule any
atom out there
those are two different mechanisms so
either light goes straight to your eye
through air to all the molecules through
the wall of air
of this wall of gas
or it doesn't it gets trapped somehow
and it only re-emits to your eye
whatever frequency uh
you know gives you that blue color
it's one of the two it can't be both
okay
okay here are the possibilities okay
let's look at the possibilities here
either photon goes through empty space
of the atom right remember uh mr
rutherford says an atom is mostly empty
space and so people have this idea that
a photon can go through that empty space
part of the atom
or a photon strikes an electron bead in
which case there's two versions there
one is that it absorbs
this wave or this energy whatever they
call it
and
and then it doesn't go through and
another one is that if the
photon the energy gets
hits this electron bead the electron
beat then re-emits that same frequency
or energy or whatever
and then
another version is that the photon can
travel between two atoms which is what
all these people are saying that if it
doesn't get caught in any shape way
shape or form then it reaches your eye
okay
the other one that nobody considers is
the fact that rutherford showed that you
know certain type of particles hit the
proton and that's why they bounce back
why doesn't the photon strike the photon
the proton and bounce back
or does it i mean nobody talks about the
photon hitting the proton everybody just
talks about the photon hitting the
electron okay and then there's another
possibility here and that's the photon
fails to hit any atom okay
and the question is is that possible i
mean if you look at the one on top it
went through two atoms because there
were only two atoms what if you have a
a bunch of atoms you have layers upon
layers like i said before a pool of
water 10 feet of water you've got
gazillions of atoms here and you're
saying that that photon is not going to
strike any atom when it goes through
there
and this is the same version here but
with a wave okay so if you're a wave guy
well there uh there you have the waves
the question is what is a wave but even
if we concede the wave we have the same
questions does a photon go through
like between two atoms does it go
through the empty part of the atom or
does it
get relayed once it strikes the electron
okay those are the
main probabilities uh the main
possibilities okay
okay here we have uh
the situation we have the fall looking
through a window
and what we have is that the sun is
according to these people is sending the
waves
to his eyes as if
air wasn't there
okay
so transparent according to these and
the glass as well by the way
so it's like the glass
and the air uh are inexistent as far as
they're concerned
you know it's like
the the
sun just sends uh the waves to his eye
directly it's those that those waves or
photons that do not get caught by the
silicon dioxide or the oxygen in the
room
the air in the room right that reaches
eyes
okay that's that's their
uh
theory
here we put some a little bit of air
okay let's put some air in there and uh
so what these people are saying that
that wave goes through all those
molecules that are floating around not
to mention the ones with that make up
the glass but here we're only having the
air molecules and these folks are saying
that
the waves of light go through all these
molecules and i didn't draw them all i
mean there's gazillions more than what
you see there
and it doesn't those waves of light or
those photons never hit a single one of
these just goes through them
this is what they're saying
okay
so keep all this in mind okay
what do we propose instead well we
propose that this is the way you're
supposed to look at this whether you're
talking about glass or air what you have
is relaying of the signal through
uh from atom to adam
through the ropes that interconnect them
so you're talking about something
traveling at the speed of light
so you see the window instantaneously
essentially
and does that mean that uh the the image
from the window is coming to your eye
through nothing
no it's being relayed from adam to adam
through all the wall of air that you
have between you and the window
the uh signal is going from molecule to
molecule from atom to atom from the
window to your eye
so you have this interference there you
have a relay race
from atom to atom that's our argument
okay
so no nothing goes through walls it
doesn't matter if you put water though
the wall is made of water or of uh
what is it the cement
nothing goes through walls
okay so you we have to explain these
mechanisms and the mechanism is that
light does not
go through
atoms
what it does is the rope
ends in an atom stimulates that atom
doing its quantum jump all this at the
velocity of light we're talking about
gazillions of gazillions of gazillions
of atoms
re-emitting that signal to the next atom
which re-emits it to the next one all at
the speed of light
okay because it's chit chi
so uh you get the signal directly from
the window assuming that's what you're
staring at you get it from the window
directly to your eye at the speed of
light through this relay race going from
atom data
it's all like if
then it is as if the
air wasn't there because they're all
relaying that signal why because it has
the frequency that it can be
sent
as if the light wasn't there okay so
uh it blocks some light you know like in
the case of silicon dioxide uh window it
would br
a block for example ultraviolet light
that would not reach
but what continues is uh
the the regular light that you receive
from the window
okay so that's the the atom that's
stimulating
uh that signal that if your window is
brown that's the atom that's that's the
frequency that's being sent to your eye
all the others are absorbed
and so again it's a relay race according
to us okay
and
we have a bigger problem which is the
quantum atom and that's this
thing that they have the planetary atom
they have different orbitals and there
you see the electron bead
blue
going from a lower orbital to a higher
orbital or you could say from a lower
energy level to a higher level energy
level and vice versa
so what's the problem with this well
even if we concede this we have a
problem here because you know we can't
understand why that
blue
bead doesn't leave spontaneously it
doesn't leave the atom
or fall to the center of the atom we
don't understand that just by looking at
this that's never been explained and
quantum cannot explain that they just
use this model but they never explain it
they they can't justify it but uh what
happens if we um start throwing some
photons at it okay
and here we throw some photons okay
these red little balls that are coming
in there
and remember that when the atom
um falls to a lower energy level it
emits and when it rises it absorbs okay
so um
you got to keep that in mind and the
question here is assuming we can see
this atom right this model of the atom
uh the question is
you have a this little bead this little
red
bead
and it just happens to hit the little
blue bead
and both of these are zero dimensional
they don't have any diameter or radius
they have no size
but even if you give them a little bit
of size i mean how
what is the possibility that the photon
will just happen to hit
that electron bead and be absorbed
what happens to all the other beads that
come i mean if you're talking about
gazillions of photons coming to that
atom well one of them or a few of them
might knock that electron to a higher
level or whatever but um but what
happens to all the others do they just
go through
so again we're talking about going
through the atom no matter how you look
at this
okay so
keep that in mind there's the they don't
have a solution to all these because
they never drew they never illustrated
what they're talking about
they don't care to
because they don't understand it
themselves
okay so here we have a a wall and we'll
call this glass
okay so these are the
atoms okay now we're gonna shoot some um
photons at it okay let's use some photo
photons there we go
okay
we have the first layer then we have a
second layer and a third layer
okay i guess the more uh material you
put in there the
uh more that bounce out i guess or the
fewer that go through
but this is the notion that they have
all these photons are just going through
the film whatever that film is it could
be water it could be air it could be
silicon dioxide you know glass okay so
the photons are going through okay
now some of them um
you know strike the surface okay and
just bounce back okay or go through then
you have reflection here you have
reflection some hit and bounce out
others go through
okay so it's a pretty big mess there
because you have all these photons some
go through it because the film could be
transparent
uh some refract
means that they take a different angle
once they
hit the film and others bounce back
outwards
how does mother nature do all these
things i mean some bounce out some go
through some go through but turn the
corner you know go at an angle
okay
how can how does mother nature do this
thing
okay and so here we see the uh what
we're proposing if i can find it here
a second here there we go this is our
model of that same thing a little better
organized you know what you have is
light coming in again from the left
and it goes to this film that's there
and some of them
are transparent some go straight some
are
at an angle which means they're being
refracted
okay
so not all of them go straight not all
and uh and again you get the reflection
along the same rope so you have
reflection refraction and transmission
or you could say i call it relay but
it's a transparency okay so you have it
all there okay you can have uh light
just go straight just simply stimulating
the film and going out the other end you
can have it go at an angle which is
refraction and you can have reflection
along the same
line in which that film came
like kane
okay so this is our model compared to
again here's their model little
balls
[Laughter]
you know
you figure it out you figure out which
one is uh
is the more uh palatable to you
okay
uh here's uh what i talked about earlier
that you can see the bottom of a pool
okay
so if you uh want to run the test people
who like to do experiments here you have
a chance to do your experiment just
throw a nickel or a shoe or whatever to
the bottom of the pool see if you can
see it if you can see it that light
coming from the bottom of the pool is
coming through gazillions of atoms or
molecules of water that's what you got
to explain and you you're going to tell
me that that photon ball or that wave or
whatever you're going to use as a
medium
uh zigzagged or somehow made it through
all those atoms
well i don't know you got a problem
there because and again you see there
the guy on the right he's looking
through a little bit of cardboard
and he can't see through it he can't see
uh in other words it's opaque
whereas water a lot thicker
a lot more atoms and you can see through
it
so
this is what you gotta explain this this
is uh
what's on your table if you want to
explain reflection refraction and
uh uh transparency
okay give me a second here
uh we did an experiment with my son i
showed this sometime in the back in the
past and that's uh we put a mirror
in a trash can filled it up with water
and you can see all the way to the
bottom okay so this is more or less like
the shoe that i was talking about you
can put your shoe at the bottom of the
water
here we filled it up and filled the tank
up with water
and we can see the mirror all along in
fact we filled it up
and you can see the mirror all that
the light from the mirror comes up and
we can see our ourselves down there
okay so
hopefully we did not see the reflection
at the surface okay
that's what we were trying to show there
okay
okay let's move on here here are my main
points okay
for those who
question whether i explain transparency
i think i did
i'm explaining that
light comes in
how through a rope there's a torsion
stimulates the atom okay and that one
stimulates the other atom and it comes
out the other end
that's transparency for you
what part of that mechanism did you not
understand
okay
uh he said i didn't explain yeah that is
the explanation sorry it doesn't get any
better than that that's kindergarten
stuff
now if he says why is this one opaque
and why is that one transparent that's a
separate issue but he can't say that i
have not explained transparency
transparency means torsion being relayed
from one atom to the other behind
you know the uh from in the opposite
direction from where uh or in the same
direction sorry from where the light
came
okay that's transparency and i thought i
explained it he says i didn't well he
didn't understand it he's still
struggling with the kindergarten stuff
anyways here are the main points qm
quantum mechanics does not have a
physical interpretation in other words
an explanation for reflection
uh or refraction for that matter science
uh is equal to explanations if you don't
explain you're not a scientist
physics is physical interpretations okay
so quantum mechanics uh
is not a part of physics why because
they cannot explain they cannot explain
the mechanism that's essentially it they
don't have a physical interpretation for
reflection for refraction for um
what is it
transparency opaque for none of that
they don't they can't explain it they
just say uh transparency means that some
of the light got through because it
wasn't caught
out of gazillions of atoms none of them
caught it
that's pretty good uh shooting there you
know
okay and then uh so qm is not equal to
science and we must first debunk quantum
mechanics before we can move on
to something to consider an alternative
because right now that's that's what's
standing in the way quantum mechanics
right
we have to establish by by debunking i
mean uh you know that it's irrational
showing that it's irrational
here's uh
what they
talk about when they talk about
refraction and essentially reflection
opaque any of those
the establishment only calculates angles
okay every time they say well what is
reflection what is your refraction they
immediately start talking about angles
i don't
care about your stupid angles i don't
want to hear about your angles i want to
know the mechanism not the angles
they measure the angle say i measure the
angle give me my no
who cares your angle that's the question
of saying like i measured the table it
measures one meter give me my no
is that science just measuring and
saying this is the angle those are
things that don't require any mental
capacity the mental capacity is figuring
out how the magician did the trick
that's where you got to break your head
quantum mechanics uh no rational
physical interpretation for anything
they have no explanations and they can't
rationalize it with waves they can't
rationalize any of those phenomena with
waves you cannot rationalize it with
discrete beads the so-called quantum
okay the
the unit of quantum mechanics
and uh don't take it from me here's mr
feynman he tells you will you understand
what i'm telling you going to tell you
you think
no it says you think i'm going to
explain it to you so you can't
understand it no you're not going to be
able to understand it you see my physics
students don't understand it either that
is because i don't understand it nobody
does
well i am describing to you how nature
works you won't understand why nature
works that way in other words the
mechanism is what he cannot explain but
you see nobody understands that i can't
explain why nature behaves in this
peculiar way why because he cannot
explain a mechanism
and why can't he explain the mechanism
because he's trying to simulate it with
waves and particles anyone using waves
and particles should be kicked out of
science because
it's been shown at least in the last 400
years that neither one neither waves nor
particles can give you a rational
physical interpretation of how mother
nature does her stuff
that's where the problem is
you got to get rid of you know you got
to raise the board and start all over
say okay where did we go wrong we went
wrong with a wave we went wrong with a
particle
that's what we have to raise we can't
continue using it waves and particles so
here's my conclusions okay
that is a not equal to a transverse wave
okay there is no such thing as a wave
those are moving vectors scary stuff
light is not equal to a stream or
particle of discrete
particles right discrete the
beads
corpuscles grains of sand whatever you
want to call
quantum mechanics has no rational
explanation for what transparency
reflection refraction opaqueness none of
them they cannot explain any of those
they say that's not science that's
philosophy
okay reflection is not equal to bouncing
balls opaque is not equal to dead photon
balls not that the
photon ball comes and dies there okay so
that's not opaque
not the mechanism of opaqueness
transparent uh didn't strike anything is
is that what transparent means that it
just didn't strike anything wasn't
absorbed so it kept going
you received the light directly from the
sun
because
none of the air molecules stopped that
ray of sun you receive it directly in
your eye huh is that what it is
yeah so light goes through walls right
okay refraction uh is not equal to
passing through
okay
in other words uh for refraction you
have to have that angle you have to have
something that deviates it okay now with
ropes you can explain at least that you
know you have that straightness going in
and you have the straightness at an
angle
how do you do that with particles how
did how did the particle suddenly you
know swerve
at such a
sharp angle and go straight again
how do you do that with particles
how do you do it with waves i mean why
would the wave
go you know let's say 30 degrees from
from the uh normal
so here here's your wave coming in
straight to the mirror or to the glass
let's say the glass and suddenly it goes
at an angle to the side it could be a
prism could be anything there right so
it goes to the side how do you do that
with waves how do you do that with
particles
but with a rope if every atom is
connected you connect the dots
then at least you can conceptualize that
yeah the rope gives a signal to that
first atom which sends it to through an
angle to the other atom okay
and yeah you're going to ask me well why
does it go in that very well that's a
subject matter for another day right now
we're still struggling with the
kindergarten stuff right now we're
trying to understand the mechanism
people think that light goes through
walls
that's the problem we need to sell this
kindergarten stuff first
okay um reflection refraction
transparent equals to relay everything's
done through relay you can only explain
that as far as i'm concerned the only
way you can explain is if all atoms in
the universe are interconnected
physically interconnected in this case
by a torquing rope or torquing ropes
plural
wave and particle uh they have to fly
they have to strike and they have to
resend
in the best cases uh
in the case of transmission you know
transparency it doesn't hit anything and
you explain that one to me i i i don't
know how a photon can do all that magic
trick
rope torques in situ bi-directionally
very easy to understand light uh works
as a chain reaction remember
like fireworks
you hit that first one that one sends it
in different directions those also send
it in different directions and so on so
light
and remember you're talking about
gazillions of atoms gazillions of ropes
photons
okay so you're talking about a world in
which
you're talking about something so small
you cannot even imagine it that's how
small this thing is
and you talk about millions and millions
and millions of millions of atoms and
ropes
so i thought
we simulated with one rope just to show
you the mechanism but you got to think
of this as
something so small and so numerous that
it's unimaginable okay that's that's
important okay to put in that context
okay uh reflection refraction
transparent
always work straight light always
travels
straight the only way you can get it to
travel straight guarantee that it
travels straight is if you have a
mediator that is taught that is
stretched out taut
okay
it's tight
yeah
tightrope walker can walk on it
uh adam man you know just balancing
himself
one way waves particles can't do
straight that's the problem you know you
cannot explain straightness with
particles especially if everything in
the universe is moving
especially if you
introduce or
factor warp space
all bets are off then not only are we
moving but we have warped space and
they're talking about what that
particles travel straight
or erected linearly
impossible
um especially through warfare again and
uh rope extends straight it doesn't
travel straight
it just extends straight okay and for
our
world
we can say that the rope is straight
obviously it's an undulated you know
entity
it looks like this
you cannot say that straight you can
only say that maybe the axis that runs
along a top rope is completely straight
yeah
but for all practical purposes for what
we're talking about the
invisible
skinny
thin
world of mother nature
a rope is straight
for our for our macro world you can say
that's the straightest thing you can
imagine
okay
okay
uh so let's get on with the questions
okay we have one fellow he says
um
reflection of light occurs when waves
encounter a surface that does not absorb
the energy of the radiation
again
all we can do is show
this
there it is okay
and
yeah there's no object called wave
period we're done okay until you can
tell us what a wave looks like what it
is if it's different than that i mean
you know then uh
then
you don't have it you don't have a
starting point you can't talk about the
wave doing this or that because there is
no physical object called the wave wave
is a bunch of vectors unless you again
you have a different notion of a wave
that's the notion of
mathematical physics so if you get
something else hey show us
okay another fella says or asks he says
no a gas certainly isn't an object
all definitions for the states of matter
and use today are temporal in other
words involving time right average
motion of molecules if you want to
define gas or liquid as
euphemisms for the collection of atoms
that behaves this or that way that's
your call but plasma falls under this
definition either plasma is charges in
motion or gas is
rarefied material you can't have both
either static or dynamic for all
my poor dears fellow
okay let's uh show this poor fellow what
he doesn't understand here let's put him
up there
uh here we have um gas let me put this
one here
here we have a
gas on the left-hand side we don't know
what that gas is what that gas is made
out of or whatever we don't care we'll
call it gas that's the name we use to
refer to that smoke to that bundle of
molecules of atoms
and you can see uh we have a photograph
there in other words you have a picture
there's nothing moving in that image
okay on the other hand plasma
plasma you have to have it's
defined as ionized gas
so you have to have ionized whatever
ionized means it means there's something
in motion in there the electron
using the quantum version right which is
the one everybody who uses plasma refers
to
you have to have the electron separated
from the atom and it's not that it's
floating around
uh only it's that
in order for you to have plasma there
has to be constant
removal of electrons and recombination
so your picture your picture already
embodies motion
okay i don't know if this gets through
your tiny brain
but
[Music]
what you have is plasma you have to
remove the electron from the atom
and then you have to put it back in
during a photograph so when you take the
picture you have to have that motion in
your picture in order for it to be
plasma you don't need that with gas gas
is just a bunch of molecules just like a
table is a bunch of molecules just like
a rock is a bunch of molecules that's
got to do with meteorology okay we don't
use meteorology and science so anyone
who defines gas as something that's in
motion or whatever he's he doesn't have
a slightest clue okay he must be a
mathematician
in science we define a gas as just a
bunch of molecules that are there so it
doesn't matter we don't define a bunch
of molecules what we say is we point and
we say that's gas okay and there you
have a red or reddish gas okay we took a
picture of it we don't know what it's
made out of okay all we know it's got
shape
what's the shape of air around the earth
it's a shell shape it's like a shell
that covers the earth
okay that gas we call oxygen or or
air
that's it
we don't have to have air moving in
other in order for it to be in uh to
talk about air plasma it has to remove
the electron it has to remove the
electron during your photograph
how do you do that
okay
so you plasma is not a photograph you
can't take a picture of plasma because
plasma is constantly being ionized
okay and i don't know if that got
through your tiny brain but i just want
to make sure that you that i said it
okay so uh please try to be a little
smarter next time
uh
because you're uh
you don't understand what you're saying
there that's essentially it
yeah there's uh i don't know what this
charges in motion is we don't have
charges in science so anyone using the
word giant charges already is a
mathematician and not a scientist so i
don't care what they use out there in
the ordinary speech we're talking about
science here we're talking about
scientific language science
words that we're going to use in physics
in order to convey
a theory
a mechanism
and so we can't use the words that are
defined by mathematician we don't care
if all mathematicians on earth agree we
don't care about that they could all be
flat earthers for all we know
okay so uh
the topic is that plasma
you have to remove the electron put it
back in during the when you take that
snapshot
okay and you can't do that in a snapshot
you need a movie to show that
removal and
uh putting back a uh an electron you
don't need to do that with gas gas is
just a bunch of molecules just like our
tables a bunch of molecules and all
that's meteorology we don't care about
that we point to the table and say table
we point to gas and we say gas nothing
has to be ionized in gas in order for it
to be gas nothing has to be moving even
though all atoms in the universe all the
electron shells in the universe are
moving okay but then we don't have a
language we need a language for physics
and for that we say that we point we can
take a picture of it that's an object we
can't do that with plasma and again i
don't know if that got true to you
it takes a
religious folk uh 100 years to
understand the word object and they keep
fighting and
they fall okay so here it is
this is what this gentleman doesn't
understand and that's the difference
between static concepts and dynamic
concepts okay
static concepts all those that you see
in red there standing pointing
orientation
uh and this is just a sample okay just a
few of them direction distance and so on
straight what do you have for dynamic
concepts more or less their counterpart
not in every case there but standing you
can have flying swimming
you know uh running there's many words
that you can put under dynamic concepts
that would be counterparts to standing
for example okay
[Music]
direction versus itinerary straight
versus rectilinear rectilinear is motion
okay
uh same uh curving linear you say he
traveled curvilinearly
use it as an adverb to qualify the verb
okay so you gotta keep in mind all this
language because a lot of people take it
for granted and then they make big
errors on this on these type of words
they can't tell the difference between a
static concept and a dynamic concept
and it takes again a religious
individual many years to learn this
language
here's another
along the same lines with this here you
have it
these are dynamic concepts used in
mathematical physics okay
and they're all dynamic concepts energy
mass force time none of these are
physical objects mathematical physics
uses them
introduces them as nouns they should
never be introduced as nouns because
these are all verbs
okay
verbs and adverbs all together you know
it's uh just quantities that's all these
things are and they put these quantities
in motion just like the wave okay
anyways energy mass force time wave
plasma vortex electricity field all
these are dynamic concepts
okay none of them are static none of
them are physical objects none of them
are nouns for the purposes of physics
they're nouns only in ordinary speech
and in the religion of mathematical
physics
okay so this is the problem and uh so
when people say oh plasma well plasma is
uh it's even worse because the electric
universe likes to boast
erroneously because they don't even
understand what they're do saying but
they like to boast it's the fourth state
of matter
well there's no physical object
standalone object called the fourth
state of matter
or the third or the second or the first
state of matter
okay so you can't say a state of matter
is a physical object
it's a concept so if that's what plasma
is for sure it's not a physical object
okay and again if it's moving it ain't a
physical object if objects we point to
pointing is a static concept and
hopefully you're pointing to an object
that's not moving in any way shape or
form or just distorting in any way shape
or form as soon as it moves it's no
longer an object okay
it's only when it's standing still that
it's an object for presenting an object
for the purposes of physics
yeah you point and name that's it we're
done
if the rock is rolling a rolling rock is
not an object a rock is an object not a
rolling rock a dead cat is not an object
a cat is an object dead cat something
happened to him
or happened is happening to him
he's going to heaven
so uh as soon as you put an adjective in
front of a noun it's no longer an object
there's no such thing as a black cat
in science
okay
it's not a thing and now you qualified
and now it's a concept you turned it
into a concept because now you're
comparing it a white against a white cat
a gray cat a blue cat
cat is an object blue cat is not an
object
okay it takes again religious folk a
long time to learn the language okay
here's another father who has problem
with uh the word object i have some
doubts about object that which i shape
only universal property okay no problem
with that great i'm glad you got one
but he says stand alone and try and go
in a circle or not stand alone because
those are two-dimensional
huh
and what's that got to do so i mean
what was the argument i i mean all he's
saying is it's two-dimensional so yeah
it's a two-dimensional object
okay i don't know what the problem is
there anyways
independent uh you need a paper name to
make a triangle or circle yeah to make
one yes uh
we only point to finished objects not
the ones that you're making if you're
still making your circle because you got
infinite points between any two points
well when you finish your circle please
call us
it's not an object until you finish it
we only deal with finished products and
that wasn't the issue anyways
independent means requires no secondary
object in the picture
means that
the halo that an angel has
requires the angel for for you to call
it a halo if there's no angel
that's not a halo it's known as a ring
or a plate not a halo halo only if you
got the holy person underneath
okay so that's what we mean by
independent
can you point to it you're actually
pointing to a piece of paper where you
draw a triangle or a circle
yeah you're i'm pointing to that shape
uh if god makes a triangle in the middle
of space
because
two-dimensional
so powerful he can do that the devil
maybe you know he makes a triangle in
the middle of space that's the only
object he ever made he said bill look at
that well i don't know what it's made
out of i don't know if there's paper i
don't know what's there all i know i see
a triangular figure i say that's a
triangle
so
yeah triangle i don't care what it's
drawn on
yeah the what we're talking about when
we say what's drawn on that's what
exists
the ink and the paper exists we're not
talking about existence we're talking
about the object the object is the one
that has shape existence only
if it has location
so object in the universe they can't be
just one in existence again as people
get confused with exist everybody brings
up the issue of existence because they
think that an object is that which
exists
that's where the problem is no in
existence and object are not synonyms
which is the problem that uh
people had in the past all these
so-called philosophers that talk about
ontology and all this nonsense
they always confuse the
existence with object
and this file continues he says
motionless pres um
we're talking about how to present them
in physics again how to present an
object for the purposes of science
objects can't be motionless unless if
you're talking about illusions such as
the drawing that you make on a paper
yeah we're
we're talking about um when we say that
it's motionless we're saying
it hasn't
you you can only point to something that
is static pointing is a static concept
an object is a static concept as well
so you point and you name rock
if the rock is moving it's a rolling
rock or a bouncing rock or a jumping
rock then it's not a rock
it's not a physical it's not an object
uh we're talking about a movie then not
about a static picture
okay so it's got to be a photograph a
statue uh you know you get
it's got to be something standing still
you point to it and you say okay rock
that's an object
okay other than that uh so that's what
we mean by motionless timeless same
thing okay timeless
time is simply a comparison of two
motions
occupies a single uh frame of the
universal movie yeah in other words you
have the movie okay the universal movie
this is god's uh movie right of the
whole universe second by second it moves
along uh there are changes all over the
universe and what we're saying is we
take a cross section of that
which is one frame of the universal
movie that's what we're saying that's
what's in that that's an object
if something is moving in there like
plasma it's not an object and i don't
know how you can get the plasma to move
in a static picture in a single frame
you can't do that
and again it talks about existing uh
he's confusing object with existence
everybody does that out there object not
equal to concept only word categories
yeah for him it's it's all the same
because he never defined what an object
is or what a concept is so to him he
thinks that's the question of categories
no no there's only two categories in the
entire dictionary either it's an object
or a concept there's nothing else
there's no third
category of words either it has shape or
it doesn't
either it's a comparison a relation
or it ain't it's the only object in the
universe and you point to it either you
define it or you point to it that's it
so it's object or concept there is no
third category for that you have to
define what a concept is right
and object not equal to exist again uh
you know he talks about two-dimensional
objects he's talking about whether they
exist
okay and everybody makes the same error
so yeah we're not talking about
existence yet we're not there yet we're
we're having problems
still trying to figure out what an
object is
so we don't talk about whether objects
exist yet
can't use the word exist until you
define the word object first
uh okay and here another file says i
don't know
how you expect us to just nod and accept
your line the rope is not like the
everyday ropes you are used to okay
there are fundamental problems uh okay
what are the frontal mount probes i
can't accept a rope that's made of one
piece under tension but also fluid or is
neither tangible or intangible but
fractionally tangible
okay the what does this fellow have
problems with well he he's got a problem
with saying look it's fluid and it also
maintains the tension that's essentially
his his problem with that okay and again
what's the what's the issue the issue is
that um people are concerned with two
things one is with cn touch
and the other one with everyday
attributes that things have so this rope
has only one similarity with a uh
electromagnetic rope and that's its
overall shape what we're saying is
something like this it's something like
dna it's a pair of twine threads that's
it that's where the analogy stops and
that's what we're talking about that's
what we're saying is connecting any two
atoms we're done finished
this guy says well i have a problem with
um the rope being under tension on the
one hand and at the other
end being made of some kind of fluid
uh
thing
from some fluid material
and also being made of a single piece
so you know it's all these attributes
that he's got problems with
well the issue is here and this is what
uh
what i throw at him because this is
where he's got to start okay because
it's easy to again a crit a critic is
not a scientist scientist someone who
explains who proposes okay and so we
want him to be a scientist and this is
what he's got to do okay
so the fact that he can't accept
something is religion that's his belief
his opinion
that's great he can keep it to himself
it doesn't involve science
it's actually we have to propose
an alternative you have to get inside
the ring and fight
okay there's no other way
religionists get hung up on a c-touch
issue
uh they compare the rope with everyday
ropes
okay
especially all the attributes you know
we're saying we're only talking about
one uh attributes the shape well we can
also talk about torsion you know because
we can simulate
uh torsion along a rope
um
again critics are not scientists okay so
it's not an issue of criticizing it's an
issue of proposing what do you propose
instead
so here we have physics is done with
objects okay you have to have an object
there must be a mediator okay and so
your job is to propose an alternative
okay so uh
you're saying where did i get some of
these attributes how can it be
fluid and at the same time be under
tension and at the same time if it's
fluid how can it not be made of smaller
parts and all these other good things
and i've addressed each one of those
separately and why we have to conclude
with all these assumptions all these
attributes
and
just to give you one
uh the thread
not the rope but the thread cannot be
made of parts it cannot be made of
something
simpler or smaller or
it's not made of anything
why because it's the elementary
particle
thing
that makes up everything else you got to
stop somewhere the buck must stop
somewhere
you can't continue saying well what is
it made out of well it's made out of all
these particles oh what is each particle
made out of what's made of more
particles and so on down on it you'll
never finish
obviously that's an irrational
line of questioning
you have to stop somewhere and say
there's something that makes up
everything else okay so the thread
cannot be made of something else
okay
now
the rope twi the thread twines around
makes the rope and with that we can
explain light we can explain why atoms
are attached to each other why gravity
why
magnetism we explain a lot of things
with this
uh assumption
and you say well but how about this and
this and that well yeah again mother
nature has a weird world we do concede
that everybody concedes that the
question is where do we make the least
number of assumptions right now with
quantum you cannot even visualize the
mechanisms
so there's a big difference with the
rope model which we can visualize the
mechanism
and quantum and
mathematical physics in general where
you cannot visualize the mechanism you
cannot even illustrate it
what is feynman gonna illustrate for uh
reflection okay
this is the question and he's telling
you although we don't understand it
meaning he cannot illustrate it that's
what he means
because whatever he pulls
uh puts on the board
it's gonna be super more than
supernatural it's gonna be irrational he
cannot explain why that electron bead
doesn't fall or fly out of the atom
this is the issue
see ours are at least we can show you a
model that we don't have to worry about
those things we have to worry about
some other things some fundamental
things that you're mentioning but again
uh we're conceding that mother nature's
world out there has some of the
properties of our macro world fluidity
tension and so on and it doesn't work in
the same way as it works in our macro
world we're saying that up front
and so for you to mix
liquidity or fluidity with um
made of parts meteorology and with how
do you explain tension with that that
you have a problem the only reason you
have a problem is you're
applying everything from macro world to
this uh invisible world of mother nature
that's different than not even being
able to rationalize the mechanism which
is the problem with quantum mechanics
so first let's destroy quantum mechanics
because right now that's that's the
religion that we have to beat okay so
that's the situation that's the context
here
okay um
we had some flat earthers come along
and one fella says there he says
the earth does i i just i can't imagine
21st century we have people who believe
in the flat earth
to me this is just mind-boggling okay
the earth does not move around the sun
oh okay thank god we've woken up and
found there's no scientific evidence of
that
scientific evidence what's that there's
no such thing as scientific evidence
evidence belongs to religion
okay evidence means they're going to
convince you of something the the
prosecutor is trying to convince you of
his side of the case so he presents
evidence
to show you that you know usually
witnesses
to show you that he's right
yeah we don't there's no such thing as
scientific evidence that term belongs
strictly to religion
it's a model yeah that's what science is
we present a model so that you
understand it we're done okay so once
you understand the model we're done with
science earth measures planar level and
stationary oh okay so you do have a
religion you're proposing that uh you're
gonna measure and it's flat
okay uh
uh yeah i mean if if i measure my floor
here it's pretty flat
yeah but the question is whether you
measure all around the earth it's
whether it's flat do you have a long
enough measuring tape to measure you
know a quarter of the earth
my god but anyways uh the issue is that
yeah the earth
they have instead the sun and the moon
moving around the earth where did he get
that they have the sun the same size as
the earth
as the moon and the other is that they
have the sun
moving around the earth which means a
move if you if you hold still the sun
it's the earth that's moving around the
sun anyways so any way they look at it
the earth moves around the sun
so but these people don't have the
brains to
even think about all these little issues
they get they drown in a
drop of water
okay uh i like this one better another
flat earther came over and he says what
he says also nobody ever bounced
anything off the moon he's talking about
you know the retro reflector the fact
that they shine this laser at the moon
and i guess he's thinking of photons
being sent to the moon okay so he says
nobody ever bounced anything off the
moon okay nobody knows what the moon is
i thought it was just a rock i mean just
grab your telescope and take a look
you'll see something like that
so uh what do you mean you don't know
what the moon is it's a round rock
that's how it is
it's a light in the sky he says
okay let's find out
he says it's the light in the sky i
think this is what he's referring to
okay so
you've seen it here first for the first
time i get credit for this okay
i think it's god holding a little lamp
there
i think this is what this guy has in
mind this is the light in the
sky okay folks
i'll see you on wednesday and hopefully
we get some more flat earth
so we can have a little bit of fun we'll
see on wednesday bye-bye